[Applause]
[Music]
but I know it's not about me your app
because it's not a hundred degrees today
that's it's almost Halloween and it's
been a hundred degrees all week I'll say
this for the Chinese they're hoaxes are
really convincing
Wednesday was a hundred and four in
Hollywood as if Harvey Weinstein needs
another excuse to open his robe
[Applause]
historians well remember this is the
time that it all changed in America on
this issue this is watershed stuff
what's going on now with sexual
harassment we're fighting all the rocks
are coming over we're seeing the bugs
underneath
did you see the Bill O'Reilly settlement
that came out this week
Bill O'Reilly we knew about it stuff
before this week it came out paid a
woman thirty two million dollars what
the [ __ ] do you have to do to cost it
thirty two million dollars victims of
the Fukushima nuclear plant disaster in
Japan got fifteen hundred dollars a
piece so I believe by my calculation
seeing Bill O'Reilly dick is twenty one
thousand times worse than radiation
poisoning
I mean you look at this growing list of
people and you see you know movie mogul
gone director gone reporter gone
corporate CEO gone president the United
States he stays what's that all of
in the Republican Party this week Jeff
Flake the senator from Arizona Jeff
Flake joined the resistance he announced
his retirement in a blistering speech on
the Senate floor he would denounce Trump
for all he stands for and says he just
can't be a part of this anymore he's the
Rose McGowan of the Republican Party
except instead of the other Republican
joining him with their meet two stories
they're continuing to let Trump molest
them that's the problem and you know
Jeff Flake Jeff Flake is not a hippie
this say hard right winger who votes
with Trump same thing with other or the
other Republican of conscience which is
bob Corker who this week said Trump is
utterly untruthful and he is debasing
the country that said if he can sign our
tax cut for the rich to base away yeah
that's the problem
you know senators have quit before their
party over arguments like this with the
president even switched parties Jim
Jeffords any member that guy in 2001
left the Republicans ordered lincoln
Chafee over disagreement with bush but
these were policy differences that's not
what's going on with Trump people quit
Trump like they met him in a bathrobe
and he jacked off into a plant I mean
but but maybe I'm being too hard on our
president I don't know if you heard but
he solved the opioid endemic epidemic
this week yeah did you see that yeah he
solved that yeah this was his quote I
word-for-word he said this was an idea
that I had this was an idea I had where
if you teach young people not to take
drugs it's really really easy not to
take them see tell people not to take
them does he have to think of everything
and then he made a very moving speech
about the whole problem he said yes
we've had drug drug epidemics before but
never have so many of the victims been
so white
but god that's not all the president got
done this week oh no he was very excited
about releasing the JFK assassination
files and just as Republicans suspected
they only raised more questions about
Hillary's emails and you know JFK he
lived in a time when bad man behavior
was never reported especially among
presidents and that day is gone as
George HW Bush found out this week yes
kids I'm talking about the 93 year old
who apparently is addicted to crack ass
crack a three a third woman has out go
forward to say that he groped her from
his wheelchair and he didn't deny it he
just said hey that's how he rolled
[Applause]
but here's the part I love
he didn't just grab the ass he had an mo
all these guys have em O's I don't get
anyway his Mo was before he grabbed the
s he would always say to the woman who's
your vet you know who my favorite
magician is David Copperfield and his
folks and here's the evidence that men
still need to do a lot of work here his
spokesman said the President to put
people at ease that was to put people at
ease this folks were said to put people
at ease the president tells the same
joke and on occasion has patted women's
rears and what was intended to be a
good-natured manner you know it's bad
when dubby is going please dad stop
embarrassing the family